tu n'avais aucune autorité aucune
Mexico que faisais-tu que
je prenais des vacances en retard
alors que se passe-t-il James ils disent que tu as
fini que penses-tu que je pense que
tu commences juste
magnifique n'est-elle pas de
zéro à 60 en  3,2 secondes quelques petits
tours dans sa manche fais encore une chose
pour moi qu'est-ce que tu as en tête
peut-être disparaître
dis-moi où il est c'est partout où tu
devrais aller là-bas tu traverses vers
un endroit là-bas il n'y a pas de pitié que
tu protèges  quelqu'un s'enfuit pour
moi pourquoi devrais-je te faire confiance
parce qu'en ce moment je suis ta meilleure chance
de rester en vie
cette organisation sais-tu comment ça
s'appelle son nom est Spectre sais-tu qui les
relie tous moi bienvenue James tu
m'as rencontré tellement  fois oui tu ne m'as jamais
vu
ce qui t'a pris si longtemps
c'est vraiment ce que tu veux vivre dans l'
ombre chasser être chassé toujours
seul
je n'arrête pas d'y penser c'était moi
James
l'auteur de toute ta douleur